the Avatar will find you he has just
entered the spirit world hey youtubers
it's Charlie so The Legend of Korra is
back after a one-week break with the
guide Korra gets into the spirit world
with the help of Jinora and we find out
how unalaq is working with vaatu let's
talk about our favorite moments and then
I'll do a review first things first
let's start off with some humor welcome
to the I disappoint dad Club that's
right Tenzin was basically getting
dumped on in this episode it was kind of
unfortunate but it was just meant to
show us that Jinora is really the one
that's gonna take Korra on this next leg
of her journey into the spirit world he
also paid off that moment from earlier
in the season when Korra opened the
spirit portal and the statue of Juan lit
up I was a little disappointed that the
episode ended right after Korra and
Jinora
entered the spirit world but it sounds
like they're on their way to where the
portals are so they can close the other
one if you remember in the beginnings
devil episode they really didn't explain
if closing the portals or keeping them
closed would prevent harmonic
convergence or if they both needed to be
open but it's kind of implied that they
both need to be open for it to happen
the way it's supposed to happen but the
real big moment was finally seeing vaatu
and unlock working together is really
interesting to see that basically vaatu
has probably just been talking to unlock
this whole time his whole life I
predicted earlier in the season that the
bender twins would actually joined
forces with team Korra against their
father and it looks like they kind of
started that journey in this episode you
know the big question I had this season
was is when they tease the new bending
style they were obviously talking about
transforming dark spirits they don't
really have a name for the actual form
right now like it's not like blood
bending or something bending with like a
bending surname it's just called
transforming dark spirits back in
Capitol City I actually feel like with
the vara kisame maka plot that Asami is
gonna be the one to actually end up
rescuing maka from jail she'll be the
one to kind of put the clues together
and defeat Varrick obviously I kind of
expect to advice you to fuse with
interlock in this episode but that still
might happen because one of the next
episodes is actually called a new
spiritual age and it's only episode 10
and there's 14 in the season so clearly
something really dramatic is going to
happen in the next episode we just don't
know what it's gonna be yet that was
actually one of the most talked about
things after the last episode a dark
avatar
if raava can fuse with a bender and make
the avatar then can't vote you fuse with
another bender and make a dark avatar
obviously part of being the avatars is
having mastery of all of the elements
and you know la clearly doesn't have
that yet he still might be able to
become incredibly powerful by fusing
with vaatu but what did I think of the
episode
well beginnings is actually my favorite
episode of the season and it still is
but this episode is actually basically
like my next favorite right after that
just because we're actually moving
forward in the plot now we have a clear
enemy we know what we have to do to
defeat them and we have a ticking clock
harmonic convergence is coming so
basically once that comes it's basically
go time I really like the way they tease
Jinora being this spiritual guide for
Korra obviously you feel really bad for
Tenzin just because he's trying so hard
but clearly Jinora just has this natural
ability I'd be really interested to see
where they go in the next episode
because obviously they're in a very
green fertile area and the place where
vaatu is is basically this desolate
wasteland so two big things that are
gonna be happening in the next couple of
episodes one fatou has to get out
somehow and to the northern Spirit
portal has to be opened and vaatu can't
do that only the Avatar can do that so
clearly there's probably going to be a
dark avatar in the next couple of
episodes but we can lay bets let me know
what you think so we know the titles for
the remaining episodes this season
including the two-part finale and it
kind of gives us an idea about where
things are headed from here next week is
a new spiritual age that might be the
episode where vaatu fuses with unalaq
next week after that is a two-part
episode part one is called night of a
thousand stars and then part two is
called harmonic convergence
so obviously Korra isn't going to be
successful in closing both the spirit
portals they're going to be open and
harmonic convergence will happen the
week after that is another two-part
episode it's the two-part finale part
one is called darkness falls and then
part two the final episode is called the
light and the dark what that kind of
implies is that vaatu will escape
harmonic convergence will happen and he
and unlock either together or separately
will defeat Korra at least temporarily
and then obviously she'll rally in the
final episode and imprisoned vaatu again
or kill unlock killing really isn't part
of the avatars character so obviously
what I think is going to happen is that
vaatu is going to fuse it in a lock
become the dark avatar Korra will defeat
them finally and then basically trap
them in the spirit world ten thousand
years is a long time to be trapped with
someone
I hope they brought a book to read but
answer this question in the comments
below if unlock is killed as the dark
avatar does that mean that he too will
be reincarnated over and over again just
like raava and Korra would I'll be
posting my Korra video next week right
after the episode airs be sure to
subscribe to get it
don't forget we have Korra every single
weekend until the season's over so it's
gonna be really exciting and
- those weeks will be double episodes
I'm also posting a new Walking Dead
video on Sunday in the meantime you can
click here to watch all my other Legend
of Korra from this season and you can
click here to catch up on all my Walking
Dead videos who is here and so much for
watching my five see you guys this
weekend